hey everybody it's Mike from
immortalflows and welcome back to my
channel I'm glad you can join me for
this video which is sort of a follow-up
video from yesterday's uh video on
cumulative Delta now before we jump in
if you've been learning from these
videos and you've been enjoying watching
these videos
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
click that notification Bell so you
don't miss any new upload right and I'm
sure you'll find today's video helpful
so be sure to hit that like button for
me and leave some comments this
afternoon I'm gonna have some free time
to get through some of the comments and
I'll pick out some of the ones that I
could use to make a new video for you
guys so I love hearing your feedback and
your support really does go a long way
in
um give me motivation to create more
videos just like this alright so let's
get started so remember yesterday I did
that video on cumulative Delta right as
a couple Traders had been asking about
cumulative Delta make a video on it and
you know can I use cumulative Delta for
my trading and you know of course you
can you know if you want to build a
trading plan around it I think you're
probably best serve to
you know wrap some other form of market
analysis technical analysis order flow
analysis even fundamental analysis
around it and
this is the e-minis today the top part
is the uh
regular bar chart Candlestick chart
price chart bottom part is the
cumulative Delta chart okay and I'm just
using the order of whole cumulative
Delta provided by Ninja Trader okay and
you can see right 830 opened up
nice strong selling right coming in you
know nice methodical sell down to new
lows okay you can see even Delta is
following then we got in this nice rally
right we went from
98 now three quarters all the way up to
about uh 14 and three quarters so about
a 15 16 point rally okay and then
cumulative Delta just went sideways
while price came down to below and
tested the low actually right we hit
that low right here at 98 and three
quarters bounced up a little bit then
came down and made a new low so we'll
just take this Divergence from
um this first lull of the day through
this sort of second significant low of
the day and you can see you have a
Divergence in
cumulative Delta right cumulative Delta
obviously much higher right earlier
got down to almost 19 000 negative Delta
now we are making a new low but
cumulative Delta is at minus you know
ten thousand so there's a big shift
there in in Delta okay
then when Market rally I rallied about
eight points I guess you know it wasn't
a big rally no 95 all the way up to you
know what is that
04 right so 95 up to o4 was at nine
points before coming down and making a
new low now you'll notice though this
time when it's making this load finally
Delta is dropping it's dropping below
that point that you were earlier around
ten thousand when you made this low and
it gets down to minus thirteen thousand
okay just for take a look at this
Divergence again still got a Divergence
because early on you had a very strong
negative Delta for the day it was minus
eighteen thousand okay and so we did
gain some back okay
so nulo here at 11 11.
cumulative Delta
it's coming in here so it's still it's
still kicking off in Divergence this
time it gets a little bit rally pulls
back down to the low sort of like what
you had here but then it bounced up and
rallied up so it went from what was that
low at the time 93 92 and a half
all the way up to you know six seven and
a half seven and three quarters
so about you know 13 14 point rally then
it came right back down so
you know here right you know where we
are right now
yeah you can draw that
here you still got another Divergence so
maybe we'll get another bounce here all
right
this time I mean you still have
Delta's going up at this point and but
it's weird right this sort of deals with
the market
um what do you want to call it uh
market dynamics I guess is what type of
day are we we're in a trend day down
okay so if we're in a trend day down
any bounce that you get that's not to
say that if we're on a trend date down
you can't buy of course you can because
you are going to get bounces
but
sometimes they're not going to be so big
right like this one was a decent sized
one went from 92 and a half up to seven
and and three quarters but this one is
kind of small here I can't count this
one even if I was going to count this
Divergence
here to here this from this low to the
equal low
you know you're only talking a bounce of
90 was that 99 up to oh four and a half
so about a five and a half Point rally
this is about a nine point rally A
Little Bit Stronger here 14 point rally
then it just gave it all right back it
went back down so understanding the type
of day that you're in is going to make a
difference in how you're trading it
okay if
if you can identify that you're in a
trend day down and really that big push
in Delta
through these new lows
in the first 30 minutes is telling you
the strong selling okay
obviously
positive Delta for the day is way up
here is this line
so we still got quite a bit of a ways to
go I mean it's not even at zero but you
see how far away we are from
having positive Delta for the day so we
know already there's a lot of selling
pressure on this Market
so trying to buy a bounce off the low
what's the capacity for it to go up and
basically trade from the low to the High
I mean that would be the ideal situation
right Bounce from the low spend the rest
of the day working your way up to new
highs
there's probably not very much if you're
on a trend day down
now
it's really quick I want to talk about
the gold market today as well because I
I was talking about gold yesterday
because if you remember
uh
okay let's clear out this line right
here but
let's go back to yesterday
okay remember yesterday I was talking
about cumulative Delta right we were
making new highs all day cumulative
Delta kept going down down all day even
and though we kept making higher highs
up until you know 12 o'clock here 12 22.
okay let's have Delta is almost on its
low of the day all right a low of the
day at this point it was here this is at
12 15.
and you're at your your highs of the day
basically and then you keep selling off
right and that's what I was telling you
right in a rallying market and this is
something I see in Gold every so often
is the market is making these highs like
this but there's just that
would you want to call it continued
selling or sustained selling if you will
whereas just pressure on the market
and then you can see what happens right
Market keeps going down down this high
up here was
1968 90 68 90. and I'm not saying you
could sell up here but noticing that hey
you know what this Delta is incredibly
weak all day and you did have plenty of
opportunities to sell up in here this
again I'm not a big I'm not a longer
term Trader you know swing Trader
looking old positions for a long time
but this is one where you know maybe
you're doing options you know zero day
options or whatever
you got a pretty good chance for a
sell-off late in the day because there's
just all that selling right you had that
buying
well what happens once that buying is
run out you know once all those buyers
run out of bullets so to speak right
because what's causing this Delta to go
down while price is going up is you got
some decent supportive buying in the
market people bidding the market that
the aggressive sellers are selling into
okay and once you remove that right
obviously this was fed day the FED came
out
um
you know but it's still even here this
is one o'clock with that announcement or
doing nothing 145 133 rather you know
we're still trading right up near our
highs of the day
and begin with the Delta is about to
break down to new lows in here all right
so you know from the 60 area
you see it just keeps going down right
then we get into the close of the day
okay open up the next day
still keeps continuing
right this time Delta's positive
okay sort of see a little bit slightly
different activity right or is this is
all positive Delta now this case all
right came down into the new low I mean
then what happens Market starts rallying
up a bit cumulative Delta's rallying
okay that's what you like to see
look at where gold is this morning at
eight o'clock all right or is it here
1935 that's like 30 dollars lower than
where it was yesterday
okay now you're seeing some buying
coming in right got cumulative Delta is
positive right now Delta once you know
you sort of get into the U.S time period
right here 7 30 what was the old floor
time I can't remember 7 20 or 7 30 7 I
think gold has kind of a weird one 710 I
can't remember now it's been so long
um
you know volume obviously picks up
once volume picks up obviously Delta is
going to pick up and now but at this
point Delta is moving together with
price
okay things are sort of back to normal
but we're still you know right now it's
about two o'clock
um
still 25 bucks lower than yesterday
where all that strong selling was
up in here up in here even here
right 30 minutes after the FED came out
so you're still seeing that
carryover and this is something you know
I just I don't know if it happens in a
lot of markets but it's something that
I've noticed that happens in Gold a lot
right you get sort of get this I don't
know who's doing that buying
um
I'm not much I don't really follow
honestly I don't follow the gold uh
Market that much in the sense of you
know who could be buying or selling I
got a friend in Hong Kong who's
um
kind of a gold bug so to speak I should
ask them
um but he's a bit like Peter Schiff just
buy gold just close your eyes and buy
gold gold Maxi I guess you'd call them
um but anyway
it's something that I've just seen it
happen more often than not and again
could it be coincidence yeah it could be
coincidence but it's one of those things
like conspiracy theories right
they come true
over time unfortunately but I've just
seen it happen a lot in gold right
there's because remember right at the
end of the day where's the best place to
sell if you got a lot to sell in a
rising market that's the easiest place
you're going to sell you don't want to
start selling when a market is declining
because you're just going to exacerbate
that decline
it's all right everyone I'll end this
video there this was just again like a
bit of a follow-up to yesterday's video
in uh cumulative Delta and you know
using it in your trading and it was
interesting to see how gold played out
after yesterday because again normally
today things seem back to normal with
with cumulative Delta moving together
with price whereas yesterday he was a
big big difference
going down well price was going up all
right everyone so
if you haven't already subscribe to the
channel again it's uh your support goes
forward to give me motivation to make
more videos just like this so I'll catch
you guys on the next video bye bye